foreign
account of this popularity attempt that
the NAACP is doing telling people to not
come to Florida I believe it was more
publicity stunt it was more for an
attempt to fundraise than it is anything
else
I might kill
I own an independent insurance and
Financial Services Agency in Pensacola
Florida recently the NAACP issued out a
travel advisory telling people to not
come to the state of Florida
because of recent actions that have been
taken by the Florida legislature and
Governor DeSantis
I think they chose now before this
reason they're looking for either fodder
to use against DeSantis because he is
now running for president
and I think it is also an attempt to
fundraise
I I believe that they see the amount of
tens of millions of dollars that black
lives matter has been able to raise from
the leftist agenda and so they want a
part of that great be trained also
I don't think it's going to have any
impact at all and the reason why I say
that is I've lived in Florida since
1985.
first stationed here as an Air Force
officer
after serving my term in the Air Force I
opened a an Insurance and financial
service business and for the past 33
years have successfully run that
business
I have three adult children grown
children who also have their families
here
and they are all doing very well
Florida has proven for me my families
and those who I know
to be a place of opportunity and
prosperity
cleanne Russell is the chairman of the
NAACP and Leon Russell has lived in
Tampa for most of his adult life and the
irony that he has lived here most of his
adult life has actually witnessed the
fact that a thousand people a day move
to Florida for the opportunity that's
here and that he would steal
issue out a statement saying that don't
come here be because of the racist
attitudes that exist in Florida
the NAACP issuing this statement saying
don't come to Florida is not going to
stop that family who has been planning
for a year or more to come to Disney it
is not going to stop them from doing
that or even tourists from other parts
of the world it will not stop them from
coming to Florida and enjoying what we
have here I would tell black people who
have seen this advisory to not come to
Florida to Simply ignore it
uh you don't come to Florida because
you're concerned about them the State of
Florida not teaching the falsities of
critical race Theory and the 1619
project and the nonsense of diversity
equity and inclusion that's not why
people come to visit Florida they come
to Florida because of our beaches
because of the sunshine the excellent
food and Hospitality that is here so I
don't think this is going to deter
anyone from coming to Florida if
anything I think is going to backfire on
the NAACP and show just how irrelevant
may have become as an organization